[Music]
i want to say a happy new year to you
all and that i'm looking forward to 2022
being a positive and productive year for
the isle of planet
here's a quick round up of projects that
will be coming to fruition in the next
12 months
the margate town deal is gaining
momentum
we submitted the first business case to
the government in october for a 6.9
million pound project to support
creative land trust
this will allow the council to acquire
unused properties and transform them
into affordable commercial spaces for
creative and support services
a new chair mr brian halton from margate
has been appointed
aside from being a local brian has a lot
of development experience in both the
private and public sectors
there's also a community exhibition on
saturday the 26th of february where
people can come along and learn more
about the projects and give their
feedback
in other regeneration news leveling up
fun projects for both ramsgate and
margate are already underway
workers started on the former marks and
spencer's building in margate high
street which will be the home of the new
margate digital project
at the moment we're removing asbestos
and renovating the roof of the building
and work should be complete by the
spring
in ramsgate we have resubmitted our
marine license application for burst 45
in the port so it can run alongside our
outline planning application
we are still intending to start
construction in may of this year and
people will have the opportunity to
comment on both applications as they are
both subject to a consultation period
we've also been busy updating thanit's
local plan
and over the last six weeks residents
have been commenting on the supporting
evidence that we will be using to
publish a draft of our updated plan
there is an explainer video on all of
our social media channels featuring
voiceovers from both myself and bob
porter our director of housing and
planning to help bring this process to
life
council officers have been hard at work
securing funding to enable us to help
our residents
our housing option team has been awarded
175 000 pounds by the kent housing group
to help us support local tenants and
landlords within the private sector who
may be struggling to pay their rent or
mortgages as a result of covid 19.
our private sector housing team has
secured over 76 000 pounds of funding
from the government for a project to
improve energy efficiency standards in
privately rented properties
which would especially help our
residents now during the current energy
price crisis
i'm pleased to announce that the council
can now present a balanced budget for
the financial year ahead a significant
improvement to the 691 000 deficit that
was predicted in november of last year
net service spending is increasing by
1.182 million pounds a 7 increase on
last year resulting in no service cuts
we have also managed to contribute over
six hundred thousand pounds to our
reserves further consolidating our
financial stability of the council
finally i would like to thank our
uniformed service team
many of whom continue to work right
across the christmas period to ensure
minimal disruption to waste collection
services around the
district you